welcome to the michaela peterson podcast
this is an episode co-hosted by jordan
peterson
in this episode we spoke with mark
manson who's the best-selling author of
the subtle art of not giving a [ __ ] and
his more recent book
everything is [ __ ] a book about hope
as well as a very popular blogger
his books have sold over 13 million
copies worldwide
we spoke about how to properly set goals
the destabilizing effects of social
media
the value of committed relationships and
responsibility
mark and my dad compared experiences as
best-selling authors that both fit into
the self-help category
and their search for meaning as men
inside and outside of religion
this episode is brought to you by
self-authoring i thought mentioning
self-authoring would be appropriate
given the fact that this episode has two
best-selling authors in it
self-authoring is a suite of exercises
my dad and his business partners have
developed over the last 30 years
they help you organize your head and
plan for your future
it includes past authoring to help you
get through past experiences that are
probably bogging you down
present authoring to help you identify
flaws in your current habits
and get rid of them and future authoring
allowing you to organize your thoughts
and plan for the future
you can check these out at
selfauthoring.com and you get 15
off with code mp that makes it 25
or something like that for the entire
set and i think there's a buy one get
one free deal somewhere on there
selfauthoring.com codemp for 15
off i'd also like to mention my favorite
salt company
real salt although
maldon sea salt is also up there but
this is what i eat and use on
absolutely everything it's mine in the
u.s and unrefined so it has all the
minerals that most refined salt doesn't
have
i i literally have every version of salt
that they have
and i go out of my way to buy it to find
it it's available at realsalt.com
and code mp gets you 15
off it's a high quality salt and can
really help with cooking and taste
people underestimate it but
this is a great one and they have these
little tiny ones too
realsalt.com codemp i'm just trying to
help everyone stay salty out there
if you enjoyed this episode please
remember to rate and subscribe
and feel free to join my newsletter to
stay in touch without the risk of social
media cancellations
have a wonderful week
[Music]
mark manson welcome to the podcast
thanks for having me it's a pleasure to
be here how many books have you sold
oh i mean if you add them all up i think
it's like
13 million 14 million
okay okay so that's a lot that's a lot
of books i
i wanted to get you on because you've
sold
a lot of books and online they usually
underestimate
books sold so i wanted to hear the real
number uh
and i i read the book and
so i'm gonna say a couple things one i
don't think
it resonated with me like it did to 13
million people
and i knew that it sold a ton of books
so i figured i'm an outlier and i wanted
to figure out why and kind of delve a
little bit more
into your ideas but um one of the things
and i think it might be somewhere that
you differ from my dad
but i also might be misinterpreting what
you wrote so i'd like some clarification
but
you talk a lot about how people
shouldn't necessarily
shoot too high because you can end up
chasing some dream and you use the
example of the man who
left metallica and formed mega death and
felt like a failure
and most people would say he's not a
failure because he formed mega death but
he got kicked out of metallica so the
comparison was off so
from what i learned growing up with my
dad was kind of aim for the highest
thing you can
reasonably aim for um and shoot for that
and in my experience uh that's been
that's been that's worked for me so
is that different from what you say in
your book
hopefully that was clear enough and not
too jumbled
sure sure and then i p and i think there
are a few questions there
yeah i take them one at a time but uh
the gold question
it's i'm not critical of necessarily
say the distance of the goals i think
there's a lot of
there are there can be many advantages
to say shooting for the moon or whatnot
um kind of the cautionary tale of dave
mustaine and megadeth is
more of be careful the direction of your
goals
you know it's i think kind of what i'm
critical of in both of my books
is people just taking kind of the
cultural definitions of success
um and doing good
or whatever for whatever that is at face
value and not really questioning um
if i do achieve these things will that
actually solve my problems will that
actually make me
any happier will bring any more meaning
to my life
um so the the issue isn't so much
don't take on ambitious goals it's more
of
be very careful and skeptical of your
goals because it's
um you know that that
that intense dedication to a goal it's a
very powerful thing
and so if you're pointed in the wrong
direction
the man who founded megadeth and who
ended up unhappy because
he wasn't as popular as metallica
i mean he got trapped in a very unlikely
situation because he was staggeringly
successful but
unfortunately compared himself to a
group that was even more staggeringly
successful
reminded me of someone i knew once who
was upset about how much progress he had
made by the time he was 40
compared to his roommate in college
yeah and this person was a successful
serial entrepreneur and and a mover
and shaker in his own right
intellectually and practically but his
roommate was elon musk
and to some degree you have to write
that off as just bad
luck um i think the founder of megadeth
broke a rule that i wrote about in 12
rules for life which was
compare yourself to who you were
yesterday and not to some
to who someone else is today and
i wrote that rule partly as a
consequence of realizing that you could
end up in the situation of the mega
death
uh founder you know you pick someone
whose attributes are so stellar in
relationship to your own that the
probability that you'll
make that bar is extraordinarily low
whereas you could
come improve over where you were
yesterday and that's actually
useful which is necessary but also
attainable
yeah absolutely and i and i just feel
like
a lot of people's kind of default
setting is to
uh you know in the book i talk about
metrics how we
kind of invent metrics for ourselves to
define what success is going to be
and i think for a lot of us our default
setting is to define our metric by
whatever the people around us are doing
or have recently done
and um and so if you're not
consciously questioning that um
it can get you into trouble yeah well
it's a it's a double-edged sword though
too because
of course the person who doesn't compare
what he or she is doing to what other
people
um are doing also can take on the
attributes of a psychopath
you know we we can't help but judge our
own actions and emotions and reactions
against those reactions of the people
around us because we have to get along
with them
and so we take into account what our
family thinks and what our community
broader community thinks and that can
lead us astray at times but
it also frequently serves as a
corrective and
stops us from what uh going down
uh a bad path that's defined by our
weakest personal point so
they often get a situation where uh a
perfectly reasonable strategy that works
in many situations can produce bad
outcomes in certain
situations and maybe that's why you need
a diversity of strategies
yeah i i i know i've found um and a lot
of the people i've talked to over the
years and i'm curious
if you found this to be true that some
people tend to be very good at
using metrics based on themselves and
they're they kind of ignore
the world around them and they take on
uh
as you mentioned you know maybe they're
not a psychopath but
they kind of develop narcissistic
qualities in terms of
they just see everything in terms of
their own desires and and
their own metrics and then there are
other people who only see things in
terms of
the metrics of the people around them
they they're very
bad at developing metrics of success for
themselves
and i mean my take has always been that
a healthy individual is able to
to do and hold on to both simultaneously
um and that's a struggle for most people
i think
most people are coming from one of those
two directions to get to that healthy
place
well i don't know if you agree with that
or
well it is it is one of the
constant battles that everybody
undertakes in their life to get the
balance between their own self-interest
and the interests of others correct
and it's easy to err on one side or the
other i think agreeable people
technically speaking
they're empathic and compassionate and
polite and
when they make an error their error is
that they sacrifice themselves
too much for other people's interests
now that has some real advantages for
example when you're taking care of
infants
at least to some degree you can't wear
yourself to a frazzle but
there is a certain amount of sacrifice
self-sacrificial necessity
involved in taking care of infants
because they're always right and
you have to respond to them in that
manner it doesn't work very well when
you're dealing with adults
and then people who are disagreeable
well they tend to be more self-serving
and they can run into problems because
they don't take other people into
accounts enough but it's not easy it's
not easy to tell
when you're when you've got that balance
right because it also changes to some
degree from situation to situation
and so your temperament can give you an
approximation
but but that doesn't mean that it's
going to be correct in every particular
situation
you talked a bit about surrounding
yourself with people and then
like figuring out i guess your goals
based on
everyone around you but something mark
talked about fairly extensively in his
book was social media
and so part of the problem with judging
your behavior off of others
nowadays is you can surround yourself
with
weird groups of people and there are
like a hundred thousand of them
that will agree with you yeah mark you
talked about that a little bit more in
in everything as [ __ ] to your book about
hope
about the effect of of social media and
it's destabilizing in fact and i mean
i've seen that happen more and more
over recent years where um you know we
just as mckayla pointed out we just
discussed the fact that you can use
other people's opinions to help you
defend yourself against your own foolish
excesses
but now that can go astray very badly
because you can go online and no matter
what
conspiratorial or paranoid twist you're
thinking has happened to
take you can find a group of people a
large group of people who
share your viewpoint and who provide all
sorts of
evidence that it's true and so
i i i don't know of any hard data on
this but i've certainly seen
a rise in conspiratorial and paranoid
thinking among my family members and
friends
and i think in the broader community as
well over the last year
and that means one of the mechanisms
that serves as a corrective for us is
has gone astray at least in part because
of this new technology
but was the moon landing really real
though well that exactly
i mean i i haven't seen hard data either
but i i did see something that said that
uh the flat earth society has grown by
like
1 200 percent over the last few years
to me that just kind of says everything
right right that that's a really good
example
if you were a flat earther 50 years ago
you know all your friends and family
would kind of laugh at you and
tell you you're ridiculous and you'd
move on with your life but now
you know there's all sorts of
communities and groups and youtube
channels that you can
hop onto and they they'll sit there and
tell you that you're right
was it mrs krabappel on the simpsons who
told ralph that the children were right
to laugh at him
yes
[Laughter]
yeah well one of the things i argue for
in my new book um
which is called beyond order is that we
frequently outsource the problem of
sanity
you know for the psychoanalysts for
example and for most clinical
psychological thinkers
sanity was a characteristic of the
integrity of your own
psychological structures or maybe even
the health of you as an organism
but i think that that's no
i think that that misses an important
source of sanity and that is that
if you behave reasonably well so if
you're reasonably well socialized and
you can hold your tongue and not be too
annoying to others and may be
occasionally helpful
then you'll be surrounded by other
people and they will hint
to you continually when you're going off
on a
inappropriate tangent you know and you
everyone knows people who can't take a
social hint um
when i've taught seminars for example at
the university
20 kids 20 students in the seminar and
there's almost invariably one of them
who
is completely opaque to social cues and
who will
kill a conversation stone dead within
seconds of entering it because they
don't know how to play the game properly
and
they're they're not functioning well
not so much because their internal
psychic structure isn't
doesn't have the appropriate integrity
but because they can't avail themselves
of social cues
they're not acceptable to others and and
so they can't
they can't benefit from the collective
intelligence of the group
which is generally but not always
telling you how to be sane
now it doesn't always work because
sometimes the group goes insane and then
you know the same person is the person
yeah everybody and
well you saw you see that very often you
saw that in nazi germany for example and
you see that in these conspiratorial
groups that are popping up everywhere as
well now
so you
a lot of this intellectual endeavor that
you've been engaged in
over the course of these last two books
um
was reminiscent to me of what i was
involved in when i was i think probably
almost exactly your age
maybe we started at about the same age
but you
you're investigating as far as i can
tell the relationship between value
structures and emotion
that seems to be your fundamental
concern is that reasonable
and you made the conclusion that yeah
i'd say that's accurate that your values
determine your emotional state
generally speaking yeah and then the
question arises
what constitutes a valid value and you
investigate that
even more thoroughly in your second book
relying on philosophers for example like
nietzsche and
and uh kant and so yeah
the question of what constitutes an
acceptable value structure is
an incredibly deep question and maybe
part of the reason that your books have
been successful is because so many
people are asking that question now
what what i think so
oh sorry uh um um i'm i'm
i'm uh anticipating your question which
i assume is why
why why is that well and what's it done
for you this investigation
well it's that
that's that's an interesting question
because it's i've always seen my work
you know and my background is just is
blogging um i'm not
i don't have an academic background in
this stuff like you do
um but i started blogging in 2008
and it initially i kind of used it as my
own
vehicle for personal development um
growth developing emotional intelligence
managing relationships all these things
and so kind of the way my career career
has unspooled
uh whatever issue i'm kind of struggling
with
at that period of my life um
i investigate it and then i write about
it as and the writing is kind of my own
personal form of digestion
i suppose and there's
i i just kind of have this faith that if
i'm going through it then there must be
a lot of other people going through it
as well
i actually think that's the answer to
why your book was so successful
is that it is the case that there's a
large population of people who are
who have the same questions that you do
and yeah
and are stumped in the same way that you
are or were
and that you're leading them through a
process of investigation and thought
at exactly the level that's
there's this idea from developmental
psychology that a man named vygotsky
originated called the zone of proximal
development
and adults speak to infants and toddlers
with implicit knowledge of the zone of
proximal development and what they do is
speak at a level that's slightly
more advanced than the infant or toddler
can understand
and that leads them so they can mostly
understand the adult speech but not
quite
and that leads them further right they
can understand but they're also forced
to
develop further understanding and i've
noticed when i was teaching that it was
often the case
that when i was trying to figure out
something out that was the best time to
teach it rather than after i had figured
it out
because then i would have forgot what
the problem was and also what i didn't
know
yeah yeah that makes sense to me i i
think
part of it is this is kind of the
hypothesis i lay out in the book and
it's something i still believe but
i think when you when you live in a
society where
information is no longer scarce where
there's essentially
more stuff for you to consume and
understand and learn about
than is humanly possible
[Music]
the most obvious question becomes what
is worth pursuing what is worth learning
about what is
worth trusting and believing in i think
if you look at previous generations
um you know information was scarce
opportunities were more scarce
and so people had kind of
from an early point in their life a more
clear path of what they should be
following
um and what they should be learning
about
and i think today
starting with millennials and even more
so with gen z it's you know we've grown
up with this over abundance of
information and
and opportunity of paths life paths to
choose for ourselves
and so it kind of on paper that sounds
like a great thing and it is a great
thing in a lot of ways but
it also kind of invites these
existential questions of what is worth
pursuing and
um i just found that you know myself
and a lot of my peers and and and
friends
kind of went into what most people would
call midlife crisis in our 20s and um
and and for me writing subtle art was
kind of writing my way out of that
it was as you said investigating these
value structures
you know going back to the philosophers
and trying to understand
you know what what their ideas around
these things were and
um and it's for me it kind of
you asked you know your original
question was what did it do for me
for me it it gave me a sense of
a sense that i understood
where i was i guess that i guess it
helped me create like a map
of how to navigate my life and um
and so it was with subtle art it was
kind of i wanted to
provide the right questions for a lay
person you know somebody who's not going
to go read
nietzsche or somebody who's not going to
study existentialism
to ask the right questions that will
kind of help them do the same thing
um in a more basic way
how do you you talk about the average
person in your book
um to you what does the average person
look like
are you are you the average person
i don't think so no okay i agree
yeah um you know i
i think the average person is
does not have the time or the interest
for a lot of these questions yet they
still struggle with them
um i think you know i think the average
person has a
generic middle class job um maybe
partially college educated but
not always and feels these things they
feel kind of the social
fabric unwinding underneath them
they they see things on social media and
on the news
that is confusing and upsetting but
they don't have the time they haven't
had the time to investigate these things
further and so those are kind of
one one way i think of uh you know you
you started this off
asking michaela you know you said you
didn't identify with my work as much as
um most other people
i mean one way i think about it is
um i'm asking many similar questions or
bringing up a lot of similar points
to your dad but i i think i'm
translating it
down further
[Music]
it's more it's more organized and
packaged for for mass consumption
if that makes sense yeah that was a
solid answer actually
that that was good okay and then one
this is just a simple question
wow maybe um what
what do you mean like what are you
supposed to give a [ __ ] about
according to you is it different for
each person or are there
rules people can kind of follow to
figure it out
uh i i intentionally don't answer that
question
because i i don't feel it's right for me
to impose my values on any of my readers
um i do simply
at times in the book i offer kind of
what i've discovered
is better or worse to give a [ __ ] about
for myself um
and i do provide i'm going to harass you
about that in a minute or two
so i thought i'd warn you about that so
you can prepare
for the warning yeah no problem
i i do lay out i think some principles
that i i
generally i think find to be useful you
know so so generally
it's more it's more useful to focus on
um
kind of what i i for uh it's not the
most sophisticated
uh terms but internal values versus
external about you know so focus on
things that
occur inside of you focus on your own
integrity focus on your own honesty
these are things that you
experience internally versus say
um you know things that you experience
externally external markers of
validation
um what would that be like fame is that
an example
money yeah money social media followers
things like that
having a nice car um you know there's
nothing wrong with those but
it it's kind of it's similar to the
the discussion we were having earlier
like it's we all like money we all like
having nice things but there needs to be
uh you can't only value those things
like you have to have a balance of
kind of more internally driven uh
things that you care about so i do think
that you impose your values on your
readers
and but i actually think well okay i'm
going to make two observations the first
is that i think that apologizing for
that is the most predictable thing that
a millennial could possibly do
because i think your generation and
perhaps even more the generation younger
than you
what they've been taught above all else
is that the cardinal more
moral sin is to judge be judgmental
right to be discriminating but that's
absolutely foolish and you actually make
a case for that because you say that one
of the most important things that you
can do
and by you you mean you but you also
mean other people
is to say no and that as soon as you
value one thing which you need to do and
hopefully the proper thing
you're saying no to a very large number
of other things
and so this is why the the the stance of
of of of the idea that you can raise
being non-judgmental to the level of a
higher moral virtue is definitely wrong
if your claim is correct that your
emotional
state depends on your value structure
and it's more important than anything
else to get your value structure
straight
and if you have a value structure you
have to say yes to some things and no to
others
then you immediately admit that there's
a value hierarchy and there's some
things at the top and some things at the
bottom
and i think one of the real strengths of
your book is that
you at least begin to do that and and
and i think you do it explicitly so you
say
quite straightforwardly that there are
five things that you've discovered that
are
of general utility that you've found of
general utility and
you don't say that you're certain that
you're 100
right about those five things but you
certainly make the claim that
the reader should take them seriously
and that they've been useful to you
and that was taking responsibility and
you do a very careful job of
distinguishing that from
accepting universal fault which is a
good
good piece of intellectual exercise
because it's necessary to take
responsibility and to discriminate that
from
assuming universal fault you can get
cancer
and it's not necessarily your fault in
fact it probably isn't
but you still have to take
responsibility for it or it will or
or or suffer the consequences you
talk about the necessity to accept and
cultivate
the ability to tolerate to accept
uncertainty and to cultivate the ability
to tolerate it
you talk about learning to appreciate
failure you talk about
rejection we already mentioned that and
the ability to say no
and the necessity of saying no and and
perhaps the unapologetic necessity of
saying no
and you also uh
you you make that concrete in some sense
because you talk about for example
that you learned as you transition from
your 20s to your 30s that
saying no to an entire
smorgasbord let's say of sexual
possibilities
was worthwhile because you found
something deeper in the commitment to a
single person
and that's a form of sacrifice you talk
about sacrifice in your second book and
um you know you made a sacrifice and
sacrifices are actually worthwhile
and then you talk about contemplation of
your own mortality as a way of
discriminating be doing what's important
and what isn't and so
and then in your second book you talk
about both nietzsche and kant in some
detail and
both of them were striving for for the
apprehension of something approximating
a universal morality
and so i can see that and you also
mentioned ernest becker
you know and and and um you know becker
believed that
you
[Music]
you totally no you you are right it's
funny because
so now now i'm kind of doing like a
a check of of my because you are right
you are correct
um i think
and it it's and i gave you i'm going to
admit here i gave you guys the stock
answer there you know when so
that's a dangerous thing to do
especially with you guys
but you know i've been asked a million
times people like oh so what should we
give a [ __ ] about and
my my de facto answer has always been
like well it's not my place to tell
people exactly what their balance is
that's definitely not true that's
exactly what you're trying to do
now when 13 million people are listening
i think the reason you get away with it
is because you're trying to do it for
yourself too you're not preaching
and you're kind of inferring right you
say this is what worked for me but it
could work for you
right yeah and let me well let me
present some context to this which i
think can
can be helpful um you know my my
background
is straight up just the self-help world
and
generally in the self-help world values
are just shoved down your throat
you know you're supposed to want in
the fancy car you're supposed to want
the perfect marriage you're supposed to
want to be happy and live
happily ever after you know it's like
these are the things that
um are taken for granted at page one and
so
you know i when i wrote subtle art i
went through pains to kind of
be contrarian a lot of ways to what a
typical self-help book is and so
one of those ways was i don't want to
explicitly ram values down people's
throats but i agree with you that
the overarching project of the book is
yes i am i am imposing um
even if if i don't come out and say it
like this is what you should give a [ __ ]
about it it's
the way i've constructed the book and
particularly the second book the the
book the second book is much more
striving for
um striving for some sort of
solid structure by the way
yeah just so everybody knows well you
you hooked yourself into
this project as soon as you made that
initial discovery like you made a
quite a profound discovery in my
estimation which was that
values regulate emotion
so then then as soon as you make that
discovery
you're stuck with it a question which is
okay then what are the appropriate
values
that make me happy well or or or even
well if it's not happy it's some other
metric you know because you can also
question whether or not happy is the
right
ultimate value i like happiness isn't it
i know you you're like it's not about
being happy but
well the hell out of being miserable if
happiness comes along you should be
bloody happy that it's
like lit on you on your stem for a while
yeah yeah but it's yeah and then as soon
as you get into that question it's
turtles all the way down right like it's
that's that's
that takes you into um
you know kind of staring into the void
so to speak which you talk about in your
work quite a bit of of
you know how there's you have to
you have to take on the responsibility
to create some something that's
meaningful in your life
yes or to discover it that's one of the
weaknesses of nietzsche i think
i mean i'm a great admirer of nietzsche
and he he i've never read anyone who
could think
with his much glittering brilliance as
nietzsche and he's very dangerous to
read because he's so unbelievably
intelligent he'll take
everything you know apart sometimes with
a sentence
he said once he was bragging in a sort
of
self-deprecatory manner in some sense i
mean he never sold any books and
so he was sort of bragging to himself i
suppose he said
i can say in a sentence what it takes
other people an entire book to say
what they can't say in an entire book
and that actually happens to be true
nietzsche could in fact do
that and he believed that we could
create our own values but that's wrong
we can't create our own values we can
discover them
and we can co-create them but you know
and you you know this in your book as
well it comes out again implicitly
um you wouldn't be able to violate your
conscience if you could create your own
values
right violate your conscience yeah
because your conscience you'll you'll
lower this for me a little you'll do you
you'll do something that your conscience
objects to
okay okay if you were fully capable of
creating your own values
your conscience would never object you
would just go along with what you'd
proposed
like if we were the sorts of creatures
that could do that but what we find very
rapidly is
we try very hard to impose our own
values
and then we then it fails we're not
satisfied by what we're pursuing or we
become extremely guilty or become
ashamed or we're hurt or we hurt other
people and
sometimes sometimes that doesn't mean
we're wrong
but most often it does and so
yeah this this and
you you're your search for bedrock i
think is
and and perhaps the fact that you never
do come to any
final conclusion is definitely at least
in my opinion
so maybe not definitely but in my
opinion
a large part of the reason why your
books are attractive you know the
millennials
you you know you talk about the consumer
literature that shows that people who
have an infinite variety of choices
are less happy than people who only have
one or two
and you mentioned at the beginning of
this discussion that the millennial
generation that you're a part of
suffered in some sense because they they
weren't deprived enough and had too many
choices
the advantage to being deprived is that
it's obvious what to do
like if you're starving then you eat
there's no question but if you have
enough to eat and you have enough
shelter and you have enough information
maybe not as much as you could have but
enough
it starts to become difficult to decide
what to do
and then you have another problem which
is that you can't decide what to do
yeah and and then you have to start to
investigate value
and that that seems to me even from your
autobiographical comments seem to be
what happened with you and obviously so
many other people
absolutely yeah absolutely and i think
that plays into
kind of what we were talking about the
kind of the radical subcultures that
exist and percolate online you know i
feel like a lot of people
are going through these existential
malaise
and they're they're searching and so
they're just
scrolling through social media and they
find something that
piques their interest seems
counter-intuitive or exciting and
and suddenly they're kind of whisked
down this rabbit hole
without much awareness of what's
happening one of the reasons that i'm
a rather staunch admirer of traditional
christianity
say even in its catholic form let's say
which is the most
traditional form arguably is that i
think that catholicism is as sane as
people can get
like areas of catholicism that were a
little
out there there still are
i mean the doctrine is very difficult to
understand the idea of the virgin birth
for example and
all of the uh this strange irrationality
that goes along with a
religious belief but the problem is is
that
we we need something structured and
irrational
to protect us from even less structured
and
more irrational beliefs that's my sense
of it
we can't live in a fully rational world
because we're not smart enough we need
something to fill in the gaps
and the advantage of a codified religion
is at least that there's a unifying
force
behind it and what you get now is this
fragmentation and search for
replacement for religious values and
there's not much difference
while conspiratorial theory will offer
exactly that but none of the true
benefits of a religious system you know
one that's evolved over time and that
that has a deep that has a deep basis
well mark did you argue that some of the
values you
kind of inferred could potentially
replace that
the religious values you mean or
well one of the concerns i raised and
everything is [ __ ] is that
is what jordan just said which is
i think people in lieu of religion they
were they are taking
worldly values things like politics
cultural issues
um social group identities and
behaving religiously around them
adopting kind of religious belief
systems around them
and that's extremely concerning to me i
mean i
you don't have to read far back in
history to see how that ends up bad
an organized religion this is something
that carl jung really recognized and he
was an astute critic of
of nietzsche and also an admirer of
nietzsche is that we do have a profound
religious impulse
and that that i'm not saying that that's
good or that it's bad
i'm saying that something has to be done
with it
and the advantage to a genuine religion
is that
it's very very complicated well the
alternatives don't seem great
yes yes and it's got it's
been back tested for 2000 years um well
and there's something at the core of it
there's an ideal like in in christianity
there's the i
the idea of the ideal human being that's
christ
who's who whose motive being offers
redemption
he had a miserable time though well
people do have a miserable time here
you know and that's one of the things
that makes it powerful back to the
happiness thing
back to the happiness so
there's a striving there to to to to
specify what that ideal constitutes
this is something that ernest becker got
wrong too as far as i'm concerned so
becker believed that our
attempts to weave together a heroic
narrative
were motivated by our denial of death
and that's true but it's not true enough
because what becker didn't understand or
didn't
didn't realize and i liked the denial of
death i thought it was a great book
was that a lot of our heroic projects
actually stave off death as well
so they may have the symbolic value of
providing us with symbolic immortality
but they have the practical value of
us not dying and so if you adopt a mode
of life that
is practical it gives you a sense of
meaning but that's not because
that's somehow papering over your fear
of death it's because it actually
provides you with a meaningful way of
being in a world that's rife with
uncertainty and mortality
you can't write that all off as
psychological and that comes through in
your book the fact that you know that
like
one thing i'm really curious about um
this commitment issue that you raised
because
it seemed to me and i might be wrong but
tell me if i'm
barking up the wrong tree it seemed to
me that it was quite a revelation to you
that
being in a committed monogamous
relationship would bring you as much
satisfaction and happiness as it did
compared to a more libertine lifestyle
is that a reasonable observation oh yeah
okay huge epiphany okay so so
two questions um
the first is what did you discover that
you didn't know
you know what what is it that being in a
committed relationship did for you that
you didn't
realize it might do beforehand
so there's two there's a there are two
sides of that there's kind of the
the alleviation of the negative and the
and the the positive side of it so
i think you know back before i had that
experience
my kind of irrational gut reaction
to intimacy in general was
i'm going to be trapped this person's
going to expect too much of me
i'm going to disappoint them i'm going
to hurt them i'm going to hurt myself
it's better if we just kind of
go our separate ways um it's better if
you keep it shallow
exactly it's safer um
so i think the first epiphany was that
that
that's not necessarily true you're not
necessarily going to
you know the world's not going to end if
you have a fight and and you're not
going to ruin each other's lives and
you're not going to be
trapped all the time there's there's a
there's a different this kind of leads
into the positive
side of the epiphany which is that
there's a different kind of freedom
in commitment which is the freedom to
uh like
one way i described it in an article
many years ago
uh was that it felt like
it felt like like if my brain was a
computer it felt like i had a program
running in the background
and this program in the background was
constantly
thinking and worrying about uh
which women were single which ones were
interested in me
which ones were attracted to me which
ones i was attracted to and it was kind
of just
eating up a lot of ram in my brain
and as soon as i hit that point it was
actually
almost instantaneous when i proposed my
wife it's like that program just shut
down
and suddenly my computer like my brain
had like 30 more energy
to focus on other things and and i
realized
the feeling was of liberation it was
like wow i
never like this is solved i never have
to think about this stuff
ever again i never have to worry about
it that's the problem with the two easy
divorce route
you know one of the advantages to being
married is precisely what you just
described
is that it solves a set of problems so
that you don't have to consider them
anymore
but if divorce looms as a too easy exit
then every time you have a fight you can
think well i can just dissolve this
relationship
and although in from some
perspectives you could say that that
increases your freedom from another
perspective you'd say well no it doesn't
it just reintroduces you to the whole
bloody set of problems
that the marriage was designed to solve
and it is very
perverse in some sense although this is
part of the meaning of sacrifices that
you can
give up a whole set of options and focus
on something narrowly and what
the consequence of that is this whole
new worlds open up for you that you
didn't know were there
you don't lose any freedom at all in
fact you tend to gain it
so okay so commitment now you emphasize
commitment
in your book in more than just the
marital domain though but more
implicitly i would say because
your your insistence that people
develop the ability to say no and that
that's necessary
which is your defense for discrimination
by the
way that also
that implies a broadening of the
appreciation for commitment
is you have to commit to some set of
values or
or you well you're swamped by chaos is
essentially the
the situation yes
yeah i i so that epiphany of of kind of
commitment in the romantic space or in
the the intimate
relationship space i quickly saw that
you can apply that
in other areas of life you know it's
it's a
a deep commitment to say a career path
is liberating in a lot of ways because
it removes
distractions and extraneous options and
things that may
you know waste your energy um and so i
argue
towards the end of everything is [ __ ]
that that there's um
that i think are kind of our especially
here in the us you know there we
we have this worship of freedom for its
own sake and i think the definition of
freedom in the u.s often gets very
warped of just having lots of
stuff or being able to do lots of stuff
and
um and it it's what i discovered is that
kind of the traditional
ideas of freedom and liberty and
things like that from the enlightenment
was much more of this like virtuous
you know having a freedom to decide who
you are
having a freedom you know discipline was
seen as a form of freedom
that's the freedom to choose your own
shackles
yeah yeah and you talk about that with
choosing
what man i'm i'm not going to say this
properly but
setting a goal and deciding how much
pain you can tolerate to accomplish that
goal and being okay with it because you
said
you know people want want to be a ceo
and they don't want to work 80 hour
weeks
i did they don't understand i don't know
i don't know what that had to do with
what you guys were just saying
no it's it's totally a part of that and
in fact i think this is kind of
i think the one reframe if you were to
take one kind of reframe from my work
that i think has resonated the most
it's i've taken kind of that classic
self-help motivational speaker question
of like what do you want in life you
know do you want the corner office
do you want to have a boat do you want
to have 10 kids in an
amazing garage you know like whatever
you want
and and twisting that over and saying
okay what are the problems you want in
your life
yeah because there's there's no there's
no escaping problems
and it's easy to want the benefits of
something without wanting to cost
and so you need to ask yourself like
what are the costs that i'm okay with
because that's actually a much better
indication
of a what you're going to be successful
at and b
what actually makes you different from
other people you know what actually
distinguishes you as a person and kind
of
conform your identity you do a bit of
investigation into the sacrificial motif
in your second book
um i believe it's mostly in the context
of false religions
but you know you make a case it's just
something i'd like to point out because
it's it's part of where it seems to me
that your thinking is going is that
the case you're making is that you can
tell what you want by
observing what you're willing to
sacrifice for it
yes and sacrifice modern people have a
very
shallow notion of what sacrifice
constitutes
sacrifice is in fact how you please the
gods
and archaic people acted that out
because they were struggling to bring to
consciousness the knowledge that
it was necessary to give up something
that you valued in the present
to gain something that you valued even
more in the future
and maybe they acted that out by
offering up a choice cut of meat to god
and that seems pretty barbaric and
archaic to us but
but that was the birth of a tremendous
idea and the tremendous idea was the
observation that
if you gave up something you valued you
could bargain with the future
and that is that's like the most amazing
discovery that human beings ever made
it's like the discovery of the utility
of work
a little pain now will pay off in the
future it's equivalent to the discovery
of the future it's no trivial thing
so then the question becomes what what
is it worth what
what is it that's worth sacrificing for
and you found in your own life that
commitment was one of those things
absolutely absolutely i i've become a
uh an ardent um
zealot for marriage i you know it's
funny because my career actually started
in
men's dating advice and i still get
emails all the time from young people
who
you know they they say what's the point
of marriage like what's the point of
settling down what's the point of being
with one person and i
i feel like i've become a very unlikely
um just preacher
for for the benefits of commitment
the more people that you take to bed the
more you're with one person
and that person is yourself
because all those relationships are
exactly the same
the fact that they happen to be
different bodies
is trivial compared to the depth of
realization that you
obtain by getting to know one person
really well
there's no comparison and it's very sad
in some sense that young people
have have have a question such as what's
the value of marriage
it that should be if if
our education system if our
socialization systems were operating
properly that would be self-evident
it's part of what makes your life
worthwhile to to go all in on something
one of the things i wanted to ask you on
a more personal level in
you and i are similar in that we've both
written books
about value and and they're both
i suppose in the self-help genre with
some detours into
philosophy and psychology i found this
very difficult the consequences of this
very difficult in some sense
it saddened me terribly because so many
people
have talked to me about
how mixed up their lives were
and how the words of encouragement that
i've offered have
helped them put their lives together and
that's a very positive thing in
on the one hand because i can
i can be pleased that
my work has been helpful but it's also
very painful
on the other hand to get a real glimpse
into how much of a longing there is out
there for
guidance of any sort and how much how
much of a lack there is of that and
that's been very hard on me to see that
over and over and over and over and
i don't know if you've experienced
anything like that
delving into the same realm
yeah it's it can be heartbreaking at
times um
i i
very consciously kind of manage my
exposure to it
how do you do that i schedule reader
email
essentially and i it's
i have an assistant who kind of screens
everything gets rid of the trolls and
the hate mail and
the spam and stuff like that um so i
have a folder that it's pretty
that that she moves certain emails into
and it's
when i open that folder i know that i'm
going to get
pretty personal and heavy stuff it's not
all negative sometimes it's great
life-changing stuff and so there's like
there's a mix there yeah well it's
generally positive
that the stories that yes i'm often
stopped on the street
and so that's a it's not as easy a
encounter to control and i mean i'm not
complaining about it because
people who stop me on the street are
almost invariably polite
beyond belief and i've had very very few
negative
interactions but that doesn't mean it
isn't heartbreaking
because people reveal the cataclysmic
conditions of their life very rapidly
in a very intimate way and
you need a burqa
i'd solve that problem real fast
can you imagine the headlines jordan
peterson wears a burger
[Laughter]
yeah well i've tried a hat and
sunglasses from time to time but that's
not
effective solution
no it's it's um it can be heartbreaking
and and it's
you know sometimes i i
i i don't know what to say sometimes and
and a lot of times i simply respond with
you know i i'm listening um i don't know
what to do in this situation you know
and
i my audience is because you know my
so much of my audience to do it it is
it is but it's you know my audience is
very international
um and so i you know i'll get emails
from like
a girl in rural india who says my
parents are making me marry a 50 year
old man who i've never met before
i don't know what to do should i run
away and i'm like
you know but and i it's
i struggle with that like how do you
even respond to that
um and so there's a lot and then
i mean it can go to pretty dark places
um and so yeah i just kind of i set out
set aside a certain time of my week um
i'm i'm definitely not as recognizable
as you i don't get stopped on the street
i don't do many live events
so i don't get it as much in person um
but in terms of like the emails and
stuff i've just kind of learned to kind
of
all right sunday afternoon is for these
few hours like that's where i'm gonna
dive into this emotional space
yeah that's intense you do get
approached quite a bit
um okay so your second book
changing the topic something a little
bit lighter trying to keep it light
it's hard to keep things light with you
around
[Laughter]
your second book about hope which is
something people are
seriously having a problem with this
year like everybody
is so depressed um do you
do you have suggestions for i guess
maybe
suggestions for what not to do that
might be
that might be easier for people than
what to do yeah
well it's funny because that that book
is a bit of a trojan horse
um i think it lures people in with the
promise of hope but
what it actually gives people is
a long lesson of be careful what to hope
for
um you know it's
i think kind of the main point of that
book
is when you're desperate for hope
the more desperate you are for something
to hope for i think the more
liable you are to just grasp at anything
that comes that comes around and just
dive in headfirst and and i think that
can get people into trouble and so it's
it's very much a book of trying to
uh provide context for people to be more
aware
of what visions of hope they're buying
into what belief systems they're buying
into
what information they're spending their
time on
um and trying to focus more locally
focus more on themselves and the people
in their immediate vicinity
you know get off news get off social
media
um don't don't buy into the latest
outrage that's you know being spread
everywhere
um and essentially just focus on the
things that you can actually have
immediate impact on
um when i when i did the the speaking
events for that book you know
one of the big arguments i made is is i
think there's a real argument to say
that we are
we have become too globally minded um
the fact that we're so aware of what's
happening in
india and australia and japan and russia
and
all these places like it makes us feel
helpless in a lot of ways
um i think there's a lot to be said of
of returning
a majority of our attention share to the
things immediately around us
to our family our community the local
school
the kids down the street things like
that those are the things that we have
actual immediate impact on and though
they're not sexy or glamorous and they
don't travel well online but
those are the sorts of hopes that you
can actually see
come to fruition well you you also
outline
something very practical as far as i'm
concerned with regards to hope
it's like so imagine that you're talking
to someone
who's hopeless but who isn't
suffering from a fatal painful disease
let's say
so their hopelessness is more a matter
of disorientation
than a condition brought about by
chronic pain or
or something like that we'll leave that
aside
the first thing that that might be
offered to someone like that is to say
that
if you don't know what to do you should
try doing what other people have always
done
and so what that might that mean it
might mean well you have a job
and if the answer is no
you might be encouraged to take small
steps towards getting a job now you
you concentrate on doing
right you said when you're in doubt do
something
even a small thing okay so you could say
well look you're not gonna
you're not gonna generate yourself a
functioning value hierarchy that's
optimally tuned to your personality
in the next week it's gonna be a
lifelong endeavor of approximation
and you're going to get a lot of it
wrong and you talked about tolerance for
error in your first books you're going
to get a lot of it wrong but you've got
to start somewhere
so let's start with what people have
agreed upon universally
and this is simple it's like you should
probably get up in the morning
you should probably go to bed at night
you should probably have some friends
you should probably have a family
probably have a job
wouldn't hurt to pursue some education
and you know you can raise objections to
any of those
and you might say that that doesn't stop
me from feeling hopeless but the right
answer to that would be well
take some steps in the take some steps
in at least one of those directions
small steps daily steps and and don't
don't upgrade yourself for the
mundaneness of your efforts you just
said you know you might want to turn
your attention more to the local and
there's nothing heroic about that but
that's actually not true in most
situations that's where the heroism lies
it's unheralded but that's still the
adventure of your life
it's and it's the personal adventure of
your life
and so that's where hope can be found
you know can you make your relationships
a little bit better can you make your
career a little bit and maybe that you
have a revelation at some time and
you decide that standard career isn't
for you
that happened to you you took an
entrepreneurial route and that's fine
but
what you did was replace the traditional
route which would be to
obtain something approximating a nine to
five job
with an entrepreneurial activity you
didn't just say throw up your hands and
say well the whole
idea of being actively engaged with the
world
is so questionable that i'll just cease
to do it
so i would say for people they should
adopt a conventional world
view and work towards optimizing their
functioning along those conventional
dimensions and then if they discover
that they have a really good
reason to deviate then they have the
right to deviate
and i think you you you push at that in
the first book when you
offer the advice to people that it's
okay for them to embrace their
averageness it sort of
addresses the issue that you had brought
up um
you may discover that you are
exceptional along some dimension and you
can pursue that but
averageness beats the hell out of
nihilism
yeah absolutely i i know you had matthew
mcconaughey
on a few weeks ago and one of the things
one of the things that he said in his
book that i really liked was he said um
he said that you've got to follow the
rules before you can break the rules
um and and i think even he even spoke of
it
politically you got to be conservative
before you can be liberal you got to
follow the rules before you can break
the rules and
i i think um that's called growing up
right discipline first discipline first
and then exceptional
yeah um i i one thing i've found over
the years just
talking to a lot of people is that and
and i think this comes back to the
emotional aspect
is that you know people who are
suffering because their suffering kind
of pervades all of their life
experience they they develop this
irrational notion that it the solution
must be
a massive huge life-altering event like
they have to change
everything from a to z in one go
and the opposite is usually the case
like it's
it's often the difference between
somebody being depressed and somebody
not is is something as simple as getting
a job
or making a new friend or
moving out of your parents basement you
know like it's it's actually
very basic things that have compounding
effects
you want to try those to begin with
before you switch to a more radical
solution right you might as well come
back to your
i was gonna say it comes back to your um
you know put your own household
in order before you try to change the
world yes and you want to rely on
incremental solutions before you switch
to revolutionary ones
it's harder though i mean part of the
reason people don't do that is because
it's a lot easier
it's a lot easier saying well i'm
against climate change than not arguing
with your husband
or trying to sort out this you know the
resentment between
yourself and somebody else that's way
harder and
way easier to focus on something that's
far away and out there
well you also get a a sort of perverse
in relationship to your own
self-perceived
ethical stature you know if if you're
concerned about climate change then
you're someone taking on a global
problem if you're
trying to figure out how not to argue
with your husband about who's going to
cook dinner
it's so mundane that it's almost that
it's almost laughable right but
but the difference between the first
situation and the second situation is
the second situation is real
and real advances can be made there
whereas the first situation just
makes you full virtuous
you're someone suffering for a noble
cause but the suffering isn't going to
produce any benefit
to anyone so put your house in order
before you try and accomplish those kind
of things
make sure you're not harboring
resentment for i don't know
your significant other before you try
and solve some global problem
in well the thing is one of the the
dangers of
tackling a global problem when your
house isn't in order is that
you don't know what your solution is
motivated by
could be by avoiding the problem right
it could be motivated by all sorts of
things that you haven't dealt with
so i mean there's reasons that utopian
political schemes go wrong and those
reasons often have to do with the
unexamined
unconscious motivations of the people
who are pushing the ideologies
okay mark this is this is something this
is something that
we kind of touched on earlier and you
were saying you had your mind changed
about commitment and i think you and i
had
similar thoughts because i was i kind of
had the same perspective
it was like i kind of had the same
perspective
anyway one of the things i have a kid
she's three and a half
and i i've seen a lot of people my age
who
are i don't want kids and part of the
reason is
because there's a sacrifice associated
with it and it's actually
quite a large sacrifice like even just
being pregnant is hard the whole time
and then well some people have it easier
but it's hard and then the first
year you're kind of glued to a baby
especially
both parents but especially if you're
the mom so there's a lot of sacrifice
and
my argument's been yeah but then you end
up with a kid
like it's a lot of work but then there's
another human there like that's pretty
that's pretty crazy um so it's a good
payoff
yeah it's like a crazy prayer in
principle it's the best relationship
you'll ever have
it's certainly the one that you have you
have more opportunity with that
relationship
for it to be deep and meaningful than
any other relationship you'll ever
embark on
you can force them to do chores
you can teach them things that aren't
true and then laugh when they make a
mistake
yeah um what are what are your thoughts
what are your thoughts on
kids well well i i agree and it's funny
because
i was one of those people you know back
in my libertine life
you know i was one of those people who's
like i don't think i ever want kids
a lot of work it's a lot of effort um
and right around kind of just all of
these epiphanies this whole period of my
life where i i
i came to a lot of these conclusions or
discovered a lot of these ideas
um it was funny as soon as i kind of
crossed that hurdle with my wife the kid
thing suddenly opened up it was like
within
weeks of proposing to her i'm like wow i
think i want to be a dad
you know i just felt it like very
instinctually in my gut
and one of the things you know you said
people complain about the sacrifice and
how much work it is and how hard it is
and how much you have to give up and to
me it's like that's the point
that's for sure man you have no idea how
fortunate
you are if you have a meaningful burden
that you can lift it's so i've been very
ill
in the last year and i haven't been able
to undertake my normal
ventures and i miss it so much i'm i'm
i'm so grateful now when i can engage in
something difficult
that i have the privilege of being able
to engage in something difficult and
you you want to thank your lucky stars
that that's sitting there for you it's
so backwards to say well i don't want a
kid because of the commitment and work
it's like no
man the commitment and work that's where
you're going to find the meaning
and then you get a kid too this is a
deal man you're an unfortunate person if
you're in that situation
but but i look back so when i look back
at say like 25 year old mark
and back when i had that mentality about
kids about marriage
you know i think part of the problem was
i had never
actually experienced
that meaningful depth enough in my own
life
you know like to me it's i didn't know
that that existed
that that was possible as soon as i
realized it was possible and it existed
hell yeah like sign me up for how
i think i mean i i grew up in a
dysfunctional family
um and looking back my relationship with
my parents
was quite dysfunctional um
and it's it my relationship with my
parents
and and my family in general i don't
think became started to become
somewhat healthy until my late 20s early
30s
um and that part of that just comes back
to you know
it's not they weren't you know they
they weren't in a healthy place either
like they grew up in dysfunctional
family systems and situations and so
they they were
they were giving it their all and doing
the best of what they knew but it wasn't
it wasn't like a an emotionally healthy
environment
you know i have a colleague who studies
maternal behavior in rats
and one of the findings in her field i
can't remember if this is her
finding or not was that if you take rat
pups away from their mother
and and provide them with the
necessities of life but deprive them of
that maternal relationship
you can see disturbed maternal behavior
in their children and their children's
children three
three generations later and that's with
rats and i mean
rats are complicated and if you don't
think so you should try to build one
and they're pretty good they're pretty
good models of people
when you compare them to your model of a
person
you know and people deride animal
research because
rats aren't humans but they share a lot
of similarities
but we're way more dependent on our
maternal and paternal relationships than
even something as complicated as a rat
and it is a real loss a real catastrophe
it's why it's so painful to me to see
that our society doesn't understand that
marriage isn't for the people who are
married it's for children
you know it's not about you once you
have a child in a marriage it's about
it's about the child and that's actually
a good thing too because then for the
first bloody time in your life
someone who isn't you is more important
than you are and that's such a relief
it's so appropriate it's such a relief
for that to happen
i just want more of the inheritance
[Laughter]
so i think look let me ask let me toss
out another possibility here and you
tell me what you think about this
well you know i've been trying to figure
out why
my book was popular in my lectures
and i think part of the reason for that
is that i've
made a very strong case for the
association between responsibility and
meaning
starting from the proposition that you
need meaning in your life because life
is hard and
so if it's meaningless it's meaningless
suffering and no one can tolerate that
so you need meaning you need sustaining
meaning and
the place to find that is in the
adoption of responsibility
and that makes responsibility a solution
rather than a problem
and you know people might think of
responsibility as the enemy of freedom
which we talked about already but
if responsibility is seen as the as the
source of meaning
and and i i really believe that that's
not only true but testable then
responsibility starts to become a good
thing very rapidly and
that's actually why you should grow up
it's because
when you grow up and you adopt
responsibility your life is actually
way better than it was before so
you're you're and you talked about
growing up and you said you need to get
disciplined before you become free
that's a nichian observation by the way
that that was something he stressed uh
not only in individuals but in cultures
so he believed for example that the
attempt by europe to explain everything
under the rubric of a
single monotheism was a disciplinary
strategy that enabled
the modern mind to emerge because once
you'd become disciplined enough to
explain everything under one framework
you could start adopting other
frameworks and do the same thing
wow it's brilliant but it was nietzsche
so it's not surprising
your book looks to me like it's
likely to be particularly useful for
people who are making the decision about
whether or not to grow up
i think i think so what was the term you
used earlier proximal development
yeah you know i i i think it's
it's very much speaking to people who
are on that cusp kind of similar to how
i was on that cusp in my 20s of like
of like okay i'm achieving all of my
worldly goals i'm doing all the things
that i
imagined myself doing you know when i
was young
um i'm i'm i'm doing well in the world
but why why does it all seem so
pointless why does it all seem so
fleeting and superficial
and so i was very hungry for these ideas
and this investigation and i think there
are a lot of people
who are on that cusp of between say
childhood and adulthood
of um recognizing that this
the the the way i describe it and
everything is [ __ ] is this
this transactional nature with the world
of everything is about
what can i get um you know if i behave
this way will i get
appreciation or validation if i behave
that way will i get more money or more
status you know i think
people eventually tire of that
worldview or seeing everything in those
terms and they feel like there must be
something deeper and more
profound or more important than that and
there is
it but it it requires these things that
we're talking about commitment
sacrifice radical responsibility um
and it's very counter-intuitive in that
way because in the true you know the
transactional nature of you in the world
everything is about
getting more you know like getting
gaining an advantage
in in business getting an advantage in
your relationships getting more status
and popularity
you know and but to reach that kind of
maturity
um and intimacy um
you have to be willing to give up you
have to be willing to sacrifice you have
to be willing to
let go of a lot of things and um
and i think that's that's uh
i you know when i i just look the more
time i spend
uh online and interacting with readers
and and especially talking to young
people it just
it feels like that is the message that
needs to be out there and it's not out
there enough
and i think um i definitely have
i you know you're preaching that message
in a certain way and towards a certain
demographic
and i think it you know it kind of
caught fire among
um some groups of people i think i did
this a similar thing
with a certain demographic i think
there's a lot of overlap i mean
you know what you're doing about that
yes just out of curiosity
are the main buyers of the book
yeah it's so it's about
55 45 women the men um
55 women 55 women okay
uh which in this when the self-help
world is a lot of men
um self-help books it's like 80 but um
it's it's slight majority women it's
generally
it's primarily a millennial audience
although it does kind of drift up into
gen x and also down to gen z
um it's about
50 50 north america and international
a lot of people in india a lot of people
in brazil a lot of a lot of people in
kind of the
the developing world that is coming into
its own
um you know so india russia brazil
how many languages has it been
translated into
uh about 60. yeah so that's pretty much
all the languages that there is a
book market in yeah
yeah it's um i i just
i think the last language i sold was
uzbek so i don't think you can get more
obscure than
in the uzbek market so now you're in
trouble
you better be prepared for a flood of
uzbek uh
uzbek hate mail
but yeah you know i think it's this is
the message
i believe very passionately that this is
that this is the message the world
needs and and um one you know when i
look at
your work jordan i i think that you were
also speaking to
i think part of why you took off so much
was
you were speaking to kind of an
underserved demographic i think it's
one thing i've noticed in a lot of press
and media that i've done and events i've
done
is that um people are
consistently shocked at how many young
men show up
and how enthusiastic they are and it's
and it's a shock it's a shock of like
you know wow why are all these meatheads
here you know i know that's so appalling
do they read books it makes me nauseated
that attitude
and it is so contemptuous and so
dismissive
it is and it's i think it's such an
important
you know in terms of this sort of
information
um i think exposing young men to
these questions about maturity
responsibility
um emotional intelligence
commitment you know i think it's it's an
underserved demographic
and i think it's it's a demographic that
was incredibly hungry for this material
and nobody
realized it until a couple years ago
well you know
it seems to me that men have to adopt
responsibility voluntarily in a way that
isn't
precisely true of women and i think
that's because responsibility is thrust
upon women in a way that it's not thrust
upon men
for example once they hit sexual
maturity they have to contend with the
probability of getting pregnant
now men have to contend with the
probability of getting someone pregnant
but
that's not something of the same
magnitude
and then when a woman has a baby
the baby either makes her responsible or
tortures her to death
and it's not like having a baby is
isn't also responsibility for the father
but
it's a much more escapable
responsibility
and so what that means to me and i've
argued this for a long time is that men
have to be
convinced and this is the role of
culture
men have to be convinced to grow up and
take responsibility
and you can convince them by threatening
them and by finger-wagging at them and
by punishing them if they fail to do so
and perhaps all those things are
necessary to some degree but
it's much more effective to convince
them in the manner that you
were convinced which is to say look you
don't understand
the game you're playing which is
adolescent and immature
is not the best game in town and
although you might be cynical about the
hallmarks of traditional maturation
that's a big mistake because you're
going to miss out on the adventure of
your life if you stay that way for too
long
there's nothing it's very very sad to
see someone who's 40 and who is still
adolescent and people who are in that
situation
suffer like mad they're usually
desperate enough to be depressed and
suicidal
it's no picnic
yeah okay so
your book the subtle art of not giving a
[ __ ] is an investigation into values
which
isn't nearly as good a title and
right that'd be yeah the way those two
things are related is
and stop me if i'm wrong okay because i
want to summarize
what you've been doing and and and and
develop from there
um
what you're basically making the case
that you have to get your values
together and what that means
from my perspective is that you have to
engage in the construction of a true
value hierarchy and
not giving a [ __ ] means that doesn't
mean that you don't care about anything
it means that there are some things you
really care about
and a lot of other things that you cease
to care about because you have to
because you wouldn't be able to
concentrate on those other
things if you didn't so it's a matter of
getting your priorities straight
exactly okay and then and all this and
this is partly
attested to by your concentration on
ernest becker
so becker concerns himself with the
impact of our mortality on our
consciousness and
and it's becker's observation and many
others that
the fact that we're limited and finite
means that our life is
composed in large part of suffering
anxiety uncertainty pain
shame guilt and we're very sensitive to
negative emotion we need something to
offset
that so we need something of value to
offset that it's not
optional if you don't have that you
spiral downhill
so you can't you don't have the option
of believing in nothing
because then you get swamped by your
pain
all right this then you investigate you
say well you you need to put your value
hierarchy together and you
you outline for your readers at least in
part how that might be done
you say taking responsibility
okay so there's some things that you
should focus on and try to change
you can do that incrementally
so if you don't know where to start you
aim at something and you try to do
something and maybe you're not very good
at that to begin with that's the
acceptance of failure and you probably
won't be but that doesn't mean you
shouldn't start
it's self-correcting so
the fact that you're i have a chapter in
my new book
uh that concentrates on a union idea
that the fool is the precursor to the
savior
yeah and what that means is that if
you're not willing to bumble around and
make mistakes you can never
improve absolutely
you talked about the ability to
discriminate that's part of
determining what's important and what
isn't and then
the necessity of commitment
arguing the same thing essentially and
then the apprehension of death
and i suppose that's partly because
to really test your value hierarchy you
have to see if it
still retains its function even when you
consider the finitude of your existence
and a lot a lot of values do not yeah
they bother
you yeah well you know it isn't just
death that does that i mean
one of the things there are worse things
than death
and and if you're fortunate you have
values that
will see you through that i mean i've
been
hurt enough in the last year so that
i learned that there were worse things
than death
and i've been fortunate in that some of
the things i've valued
have kept me afloat and all of those
were
oriented they were all derived from
responsibility
responsibility to my family and
responsibility to other people
that never ceased being important even
under the direst of circumstances
so i think that you and i
not only you and i obviously but we've
been
walking down the same road in some way
have
been fortunate enough to engage in a
conversation about what's fundamentally
important and that it's reasonable
to propose that some of the reason for
our
mutual success is that we did
realize that some things are important
but you're not a sap and a sucker to
make the
supposition that there are things worth
committing to
and that value is real
yeah there's a there's a great essay by
so david foster wallace is one of my
favorite
authors and he had a great essay called
a unum pluribus
which is kind of a play on the
pluriposum
and in it he taught it it's actually an
essay about like
literary critique but he actually
makes a lot of very pertinent
observations about
[Music]
north american culture western culture
in general since
say the 1960s and he kind of walks
through
how starting in the 60s and 70s irony
kind of took hold of pop culture
this idea of like being a rebel being
cool
um being contrarian like these were all
things that
probably because they gained attention
um
in the various mediums they came to
dominate pop culture
and within a generation by his
generation he was gen x
um they kind of came to define
the cultural values to a certain extent
of you know being ironic being sarcastic
um being too cool for school
and the essay actually ends in a very
sad place where he
he talks about this was written in 1992.
he talks about
you know if we keep going down this path
of
essentially exalting ideas
and narratives that tear the cultural
structures down
that basically say like you know that
kind of set things on fire and then
laugh about it and say like oh look how
cool i am
um and as long as we perpetuate these
narratives that
um actually taking responsibility for
something or
genuinely or authentically valuing
something publicly
saying this is important to me you know
as long as we see that as something
cheesy and worth the writing um
he said he's like this is going to take
us to a very very
dark place and
i actually reread that essay recently
but it's something i've just been i've
been thinking about
non-stop for the last six months and
it's it's very similar what to what you
were saying
that it's uh you know it's
this authentically choosing something
to make important in your life and and
standing by that and
um and making sacrifices for it it's not
gonna win you any cool points like it's
not gonna
it's not gonna it's not gonna get shared
on social media
all the time it's it's you know well
it's funny because it might
yeah it looks like it's fairly popular
it did for you
i know i know what you mean i mean
that's not the story
you know but but i i had to couch mine
in in snide and snarky humor you know
it's
um and i'm not i'm not lamenting that i
enjoy my humor
obviously but like it's
you know one of the reasons i write the
way one of the reasons it is called
the subtle art of not giving a [ __ ] and
not called the importance of choosing
your values or something similar like
that is because it's i
i found just from years writing online
is that you have to
um you have to package these ideas or at
least i do
this this is what i found that worked is
i had to package these ideas and a lot
of kind of
ridiculous snarky jokes
um to get people to to consume them you
know is the sugar that makes the
medicine go down
essentially for people that's
interesting because it wasn't clear to
me when i read the book
like that's no problem yeah that's kind
of the problem i had with it because it
doesn't
like the ideas appeal to me but that
style
didn't just to be uh to be
like blunt about it but i mean
you've sold 13 million books
so it appeals to people which is just
it's clearly not
like it's not a book that's doing harm
it is no no and it's not the ideas it
was just like i was like
does he need to say [ __ ] all the time
but i maybe i'm just like i'm just old
now
well it's interesting
said great men are seldom credited with
their stupidities
and what he meant by that was you don't
know how much
bad has to be packaged along with
something good in order for the good
to be able to exist and
that's not a justification for what's
bad but
it is an intriguing not to jump to
conclusions too quickly and
michaela's observation that you know she
she reacted in in a particular way to
the style of the book but then had to
contend with the fact that it's been
unbelievably widely read well and i
agreed with like i read it and was like
yeah i agree with there there are a lot
of points in here that i agree with
it was just a really like i just
couldn't exactly figure out what you
were doing with the way you were writing
i was like why it's like they're it's
funny too and i know that you
you have a bit of a background in comedy
but
i part of what i was thinking throughout
reading it was
why is it written this way but maybe
it's effective
maybe that is a zone of proximal
development um
issue as well but he said his market is
is millennial right but what but what i
what mark
said i believe is that you know maybe
what you did
with your style was give people
permission to
to think about the deeper issues that
you were raising
by adopting an ironic tone and he made
it cool right you made it cool
you snuck it in a bunch of cool stuff
yeah right yeah right it has a cool
title like it the book is cool on the
outside
too so that was that was obviously a
brilliant idea
it worked
yeah i mean and it's for what it's worth
mckayla i mean
a lot of people have the same criticism
they say the same thing they're like i
love the ideas but do you really have to
be like
such a sarcastic [ __ ] all the time
you know and it's
i mean on the one on the one hand it's
like okay this is this is just how i
like to
this is the sort of stuff that i find
funny so i i enjoy putting it in but on
the other hand it's
um well apparently other people do too
they do but it was it was actually very
interesting you know because my book
came out about two years before yours
jordan said it was very interesting
watching your book take off so much
because it is
um uh you know some like
so serious and like very
straight to the point um like there's no
there's absolutely no ambiguity of what
you're getting at
in in any of your chapters and you know
there were part of me
um read that and it's like
and i was like wow like how does he how
does he do this
you know it's like i i've never found a
way to not
kind of couch it in that language and
have people take me seriously
it might just be my style of
communicating well it's a hard question
because
you know one of the one one i realized
something a long time ago when i was
teaching in boston
i was teaching a very very serious
course um
the subject material was brutal uh it
was a course
that focused a lot on atrocity and it
was based on my first book
maps of meaning and i had this voice in
the back of my head constantly that said
you know
if you had really mastered this material
you could teach it with a light touch
you could inject some humor and i know
that i'm at my best when i
have a sense of humor about what i'm
talking about no matter how
serious what i'm talking about is and
you know
you did manage to maintain
a sense of humor while discussing topics
that are very serious and
it might be reasonable to debate about
whether the humor goes too far
or whether it's sufficiently
sophisticated or i think that's
irrelevant in some sense because the
success of the book speaks
for the utility of the approach also who
cares if one person is like yeah you
said [ __ ] too much
yes
[Laughter]
that's why it's useful to consider your
reaction in light of the fact that it
also sold 13 million copies
but it is interesting that that you have
some conscious sense that
by playing by maybe it's also
to some degree that you showed that you
were able to play the ironic game
you know sometimes people who are
serious
are serious because they can't be funny
they can't
joke they can't be one of the crowd they
can't be one of the guys
and so they make the claim that their
seriousness should trump that but it
doesn't but
by adopting that tone that you adopted
you did say well look i can play the
ironic
game but i found something better
and yeah and maybe that's part of what
makes the book convincing
yeah because there are a lot of other
books with [ __ ] the title now i can
tell you that
i've seen that yeah congratulations
you've contributed
one more to the degeneracy of north
american culture
you're welcome society
thank you so much for coming on that was
really fun
that was a very very enjoyable podcast
where can people go to find you
markmanson.net
i've got hundreds of free articles um
and then obviously the books are in
every bookstore so just keep an eye out
but yeah that's pretty much it
well thank you very much for coming on
that was fun
thanks for having me it was a pleasure
yeah it was really good to meet you
you too
[Music]
you